翻訳: Mamoru Sekiguchi
校正: Hiroko Kawano
私はですね 日本で生まれました
父の仕事の関係で
9歳から22歳まで
３大陸４カ国で育ちました
最初に住んだ国は ギリシャのアテネです
私の父は駐在員だったので
ポンコツでよくエンジンが
かからない車だったんですけれども
シルバーの BMW に乗っていました
私の家族はよくその車で
中心街まで出かけていました
よく行く交差点のところで
いつもそこに
浅黒い肌の色をした
子どもたちがいる箇所がありました
その交差点で信号が赤になると
その子たちは車に寄ってきて
コンコンって窓をノックするんです
「花を買って」っていうふうに
私の方を見ます
私はそのときに
全く同じ空間にいるのに —
ドアを隔てた外側と内側にいるだけなのに
私のいる世界とその子のいる世界は
全然違う世界なんだという感覚を覚えました
それは何か
罪悪感のような 申し訳ないような
「何もできなくて 本当にごめん」
という感じの
謝罪をしたいような
隠れてしまいたいような
言葉ではとても言いにくい —
とても複雑な気持ちがありました
それは もしかしたら
私がこの世界で最初に感じた
「無力感」といったもの
だったのかもしれません
私はその後 日本に帰って —
その日本の中学校は
管理教育で有名で
初めて行ったその学校の始業式は
体育館を出るときに 頭髪検査がありました
私は そのようなルール —
自分がわからないことだったり
既にできているコミュニティに
自分だけがよくわからない —
自分だけがいつも孤独だっていう感覚を
それから何回も何回も味わっていきます
シンガポールに その後父は また転勤になり
私は死ぬ気で英語を勉強しました
だけれどもクラスに座ったら
一体 宿題が何が出てるかもわからない
その中で私は必死に
「その中に溶け込まなくっちゃ」
「自分だけひとりぼっちで 早くこの人たちの
中に入って行かなくっちゃ」っていうふうに
頑張って生きてきました
日本に帰ってきてから
私はコンサルティング業界で
仕事を始めました
基本的には顧客の課題を解決する —
何か問題を特定し
そこに対して
「こういうことやったら
その問題はなくなりますよ」という
処方箋を描きます
それを顧客に提案をし その行動を
取ってもらえたら 現実は変わるはずだ
あらゆるロジカルシンキングというものを
駆使して 私は仕事をしていました
そこから 私はその 関心が人事 —
「人や組織はどうやったら良くなるんだろう」
というキャリアに変わっていったときに
「どうしてこんなに外側で
一生懸命何か行動したり直したりするのに
現実はなかなか変わらないんだろう？」
ということを考え始めました
確かに 一生懸命何か行動したら
一瞬物事は良くなったかのように見えます
けれども また次の問題が起きてしまう
私の関心は 人や組織から
社会課題へと移っていきました
この世界には たくさん —
この世界を良くしようと思って
活動したり運動したり
いのちを使ってる人が
こんなにたくさんいるのに
どうしてなかなか 現実は変わらないの？
そんなとき 私は本当に自分は無力で
自分のやってることが本当にちっぽけで
まるで その花を売りに来た子たちに
何もしてあげられなかった —
その無力感を思い出して
絶望するようになっていきました
そんなときに ある考えに出会います
私たちの内側の世界が
外側を創っている —
この内側の世界が何なのかを
知りたいと思うようになりました
外側で為す術がない課題がいっぱいある中で
もし人間の内側の世界が
なにか変われば —
外側の現実が変えられるんだったら
内側の世界をどう変えるのか知りたい
と思うようになりました
その頃 私は
人事の仕事をするようになっていて
毎日たくさんの人が相談に来ました
「部下が思い通りに仕事をしてくれない」
「自分の家族のことで悩んでいる」
「パフォーマンスが出ない」
その悩みはみんないろいろでしたが
みんな何か変えたい現実を持っていました
私は その一人ひとりと一緒に
「自分の内側にどんなことがあるから
その現実が生まれているのか？」ということを
一緒に探し始めました
その数は何年か経つと
数百人を超えるぐらいになっていました
私はその中から
ひとつの真実を見出したのです
どんな人の中にも痛みがある
その痛みは感情が守っています
悲しみや怒りといったものを
みんな一生懸命押し殺して
そしてその痛みを二度と味わいたくない
というふうに 人生で頑張って生きている
でも その痛みを二度と味わいたくない
というふうに 行動すればするほど
私たちは 頑張ってる気持ちにもなれる —
効力感も感じられる —
でも 創り出す現実は
やっぱり不本意なんです
私はこれを「欠乏モデル」
というふうに名づけました
大きく言うと「世界には愛がない」
もしくは「私は愛されない」
そして「自分には価値がない」
もしくは「自分は何かが欠けている」
もしくは「私はひとりぼっちだ」
こんな信念を みんな
心の奥に持っています
私のモデルは「ひとりぼっち」なんです
私は2歳のときに
妹が生まれるときに
母が流産しそうになって
私は 祖父母の家に預けられました
私はそのとき
言葉を少し話していたようで
多分 実情はよくわかっていたんだ
というふうに 親は思っていたんだと思います
でも私は そのときに
自分が抱えてきた
私の母親が突然目の前から
いなくなってしまった —
その悲しみを
自分で封じ込めるために
「私はどうせひとりぼっちなんだ」
という信念を 創り出したらしいのです
私はそれに気付いたときに
自分の人生を全部振り返ってみました
高校に行ったときに
アメリカの高校で高校３年生で
もうみんな卒業間近で
みんな仲良くって
私は 図書館でひとりで勉強して
ランチの時間
恐くて 食堂に行くことができなかった
私はひとりぼっちだったんです
でも私のその「ひとりぼっち」という体験は
みんなに言えば
「それは頑張ったね」とか
「環境のせいだ」っていうふうに
言ってくれるかもしれないけれども
私はそのひとりぼっちだという
体験を自分で創り出しました
私はこのひとりぼっちを避けるために
20代 死ぬ気で働きました
「自分は強くならなくっちゃ」
「誰に見捨てられても
私はひとりで生きていかなくっちゃ」
そんなふうに思っていたことに
気づいたのです
私は 人を信じていませんでした
どうせ私は見捨てられる
いつかみんな自分の元から去っていく —
そうやって人を試して
切られそうになると
自分からその人の所を離れていました
そんな自分の人生が
本当に走馬灯のように
自分の中で巡ったときに
私は はっきりわかったんです
私は 人生を創り出してきた
そして その創り出す大元になった信念は
私が望んだものではなかった
じゃあ
私が本当に望んでいる世界は 何なのか？
私がここの世界から 新しい世界を創るには
私は本当は 何を思い出したいのか？
そして私は 行きついたんです
私が欲しい世界は
身体がバラバラに見えたとしても
私たちはいのちとして
ひとつにつながっている という世界です
数年前に あるアメリカ人の長老 —
ネイティブアメリカンと言われる
部族の長老に出会いました
彼は私に こう言ったんです
「人間は本当に大事なことを
生まれてきたときに忘れてしまうんだ
でも誰もが この人生をかけて
それを思い出していくんだよ」
私は いのちが繋がっているという世界を
この世界にもたらしたい —
私がそれを生きるにはどうしたらいいのか
ということを試行錯誤し始めました
この世界にないものなんか
本当はないんです
もし あなたが今
「この世界に愛がない」と思っているなら
あなたの内側にある愛を
「世界にこれがある」というふうに
表現してください
その愛を 世界に与えてあげてください
もしあなたが 「自分は価値がない」
というふうに思っているんだったら
「人間はいのちとして存在として
価値がある —
何をやっても何ができなくても
価値があるんだよ」ということを
世界に表してください
もしあなたが 他の人と比べて
何か自分を劣ってたり欠けている
というふうに感じているんだったら
人間はみんなでこぼこで
一人ひとりできることと
できないことがあって
だからこそ 世界は支え合える —
だからこそ世界は 一人ひとりがユニークで
かけがえのない存在なんだっていうことを
世界に表現してください
もしあなたが
ひとりぼっちだと思っているなら
あなたは決してひとりではない
ということを思い出してください
私たちはこれまで 何かがない
だからもっとこうならなくっちゃ
だからもっと成長しなくっちゃ
だからもっといろんなものを
手に入れなくっちゃっていうふうに —
私たちの外側の世界は そんなふうに
どんどん豊かになっていったのかもしれません
でも 私たちの内側の世界は
自分はダメだ 何かが足りない —
そんな世界で できていたとしたら
私たちの
そこから創り出せる外側の世界は
本当に満たされた世界には
ならないと思います
でも私たちは思い出せる
忘れてしまったものを 今 みんなで
一人ひとりが 思い出すときだと思います
一人ひとりが 本当に自分の中にあること
本当に全てあるということを思い出し
そこから現実を創る —
どんなに世界に それが「ない」
というふうに思えたとしても
あなたが「ない」と思うのは
あなたの内側にそれが「ある」からだ
と思うんです
私たちの社会は 今 とても大きな転換期を
迎えていると言われています
難民の数は増える一方で
核や放射能の問題もあるし
たくさんの 本当にひとりでは
手に負えないと言われているような
問題がたくさん たくさんあります
それでも私は
一人ひとりが 本当に自分の中で
大事にしたいものを思い出すために
世界の現実は —
私たちの外側の世界に起こることは
全て起こっていると思っています
そこから私たちが
自分の内側にあるものを思い出し
そこから 本当に自分が
生み出したい世界を創り出せたら
きっと世界は 希望の持てる場所に
なっていくと思うのです
何かすごいことをやろうとか
何か大きなことをやろうとか
世界を変えなくちゃじゃなくって
一人ひとりが今
自分の半径５メーターでいい
この自分の繋がっているこの日常の
この自分が 大事にしたい人たちの
つながりの中から
自分が本当に 大事にしたいものを
表現していける —
そんな世界が 私は この次の世界の
希望を創っていけるというふうに思っています
自分たちの外側の世界は
それを思い出すためにすぎない
私たちは 幸せは 内側で感じるから
幸せなんです
何か外側で持っているから
何かがあるから幸せなんじゃない
私たちは 感じることができます
私たちにあることを 感じて
私たちが あるものから表現したときに
私たちは一緒にきっと
希望を創っていくことができると思います
この人生は 本当に冒険で
人生は 本当にこの体を通して
体験をしていく
その体験から 私たちは
自分が本当には誰なのかを
思い出していく旅なのかもしれません
私たち一人ひとりがこれから
きっと一緒に支えあって
どんなことが外側で起きたとしても
そこから自分たちが
本当に大事にしたいこと —
そこから起こる力につながって
現実を創造していきたい
「人間は現実を創造できるようにできている
完璧に」というふうに思っています
子どもたちに 孫たちに その先の世代に
本当にこの豊かな自然と
この美しい この環境を
私は残していってあげたいと思っています
私は誰よりも
その自然を享受してきたと思うし
この豊かさを
本当に人生で楽しんできました
だからそれを継続して渡していきたいと思う
そして ここにいらっしゃる皆さんも
きっとそうだと思います
そしてそれは 私たち一人ひとりの
半径５メーターからきっとできる
私はそう信じています
ご清聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）